la chute aura été très sévère pour les
crypto au cours du mois de mai bitcoin
est terre et autres ont totalement
dévissé perdant jusqu'à plus de 40% de
leur valeur
prenons le bitcoin le premier et plus
célèbres crypto actif il a perdu près de
30 % sur le mois de mai est tombé autour
de 30 mille dollars
loin de son record à près de 65 mille
dollars
ni avril dernier mais alors que s'est-il
passé
trois événements pour mieux comprendre
d'abord elon musk après avoir été noté
le bitcoin en flèche il y a quelques
mois qu de tweets fait investir tesla à
hauteur de 1,5 milliard de dollars
déclaré que ces véhicules pourraient
être achetés avec a fait volte-face
retourné sa veste pour raisons
écologiques
les fermes de minage de bitcoin des
ordinateurs travail en h24 sont très
nocifs pour l'environnement
finis les achats de tesla en pid cogne
on ne sait pas encore si c'est une
manoeuvre du nouveau un ou des crypto
mais ce désaveu après celui du dodge
coyne a eu un impact certain
autre événement la nes du chiffre de
l'inflation aux usa le 10 mai 2021 plus
4,2 pour cent en un an entre avril 2020
et avril 2021 chiffre le plus élevé
depuis 2008
les marchés ont donc chuté à cette
annonce que ce soit le dow jones le s p
500 où le nasdaq et le bitcoin a fait de
même dernier évènement la prise de
parole de la chine 18 mai elle va
dorénavant réprimer les activités de
production et de trading du bitcoin pour
lutter contre les risques financiers
là encore véritables inquiétudes pour
l'économie ou stratégie pour affaiblir
les crypto avant de lancer son dual
numérique début 2022
on vous laissera juge toujours est il
que ce mois de mai restera historique
pour avoir porté un sérieux coup à
l'engouement autour des crypto
et témoignent que le risque comme sur
marchés traditionnels et également la
[Musique]